So wouldn't it be good if in every
society where every organization,
we had some people who specialized in,
uh,
specialized,
insane,
hey,
what are the opportunities?
And then we had other people
as specialized in saying,
well,
but what are the risks?
And it just so happens that a lot of
people have trouble doing all that in
themselves.
When we have systems that are well
constituted with people who have different
personalities and different
motives and goals,
we actually can get better.
We can have a discussion between them.
Yeah.
Well that's exactly why that it's
for that precise reason that,
that I've been so interested
in free speech as a,
as a,
as a value because well,
even on the economic front,
it's pretty obvious if you
look at things economically,
that the entrepreneur types who start
businesses are lumped in with the liberal
creative types.
We've done a lot of work on the
prediction of entrepreneurial behavior and
ability and it's openness.
That's the big predictor.
It's not the only one.
It's openness an Iq fundamentally.
But for managerial and
administrative expertise,
it's,
oh,
it's Iq and conscientiousness.
So the liberals start businesses and,
and,
but they can't run them
because they're there,
their interests flipped and they don't
have the organizational ability and the
conservatives can run them,
but they can't continue to
transform and expand the,
yeah.
It Yin and Yang.
Yin and Yang.
Yup.
So,
so one more thing about what happened
in Nazi Germany that it's very relevant
and interesting because it's,
it's useful to get these motives right.
You know,
first of all,
if,
if something disgusts you,
if something,
if you're afraid of something,
then you run away from it or you freeze.
But if something disgusts you,
you try to burn it or die or kill it.
Right.
You try to get rid of or expel it.
That's,
that's right though.
You want to get it away and destroy it.
So when Hitler came to power,
he put in above a bunch
of public health schemes.
Like,
ah,
he had vans that went around and
screen people for tuberculosis.
Then he went on a factory cleanliness,
uh,
campaign.
So the factories were supposed
to be tidy it up and he washed,
he made about four times a day.
By the way,
it's also a great worship or of willpower,
which is associated with orderliness
and seems maybe to be associated with
disgust,
sensitivity in some way
that isn't yet understood.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't,
I don't understand that connection either.
So they,
he convinced factory owners in Germany
to get rid of the rats and the mice and
mice and insects in the factories and
also to clean them up and beautify them.
But the gas they use to clean up
the factories was like lawn a,
and it was the variation of that gas
cycle on B that was then used in.
Yeah.
So you could see this ramping up pay.
So it was,
yeah,
absolutely.
So it was public health,
then it was social cleanliness.
Then he went into the
asylums and cleaned them up.
And so it was just this expansion of,
of who was contaminated
and who was impure.
And I think also his fascination with
fire and his use of fire symbolism was
also associated with that,
with that appealed to purification
because the whole idea of purification by
fire is a very ancient idea.